hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
during the PS 5 reveal we saw 25 games
showcased it was pretty damn epic well
this got me thinking at the start of
every console generation games can
appear to be made for one single
platform I mean only last month I made
an assassin's creed Valhalla video to be
told by people in the comments the game
is an xbox exclusive of course it isn't
but it can be easily misconstrued by
those subliminal logos we see so with
this in mind I went through all the
games of the PS 5 reveal to seek the
truth
what games release on PC and Xbox and
spoiler alert there are a ton of
PlayStation exclusives let's do this
[Applause]
[Music]
let's start with spider-man Miles
Morales this is indeed only going to
appear on PlayStation but the thing to
note about this title is it's not a full
sequel so to speak it isn't spider-man 2
nor is this a remaster of the 2018 game
spider-man Miles Morales acts like a
standalone story much like infamous
second son and the first light Madden
another way to think of it is akin to
Uncharted The Lost legacy in which the
original game is not required to play
the new content the story will revolve
around miles as he learned to harness
his superpowers and fight crime and will
be releasing alongside the PS 5 to
showcase that new super fast SSD tech
next Gran Turismo 7 again completely a
PS 5 exclusive on the live stream
it looks pretty mediocre due to the drop
in stream quality but if you check the
vod's out on youtube you can see for
yourself
it looks great they were heavy on
campaign hint so it looks like the meaty
solo drive is possible once again for
those racing enthusiasts to feel
satisfied Ratchet and Clank rift apart
was up next and showcased some of the
most impressive uses of the PS 5
lightning fast SSD with ratchet moving
between dimensions in a heartbeat the
gameplay looks damn fun and very - but
yeah this game is designed exclusively
for the PS 5 judging by the jumps
between fully realized worlds
instantaneously the real question I have
is if the player took a different path
they encounter different worlds at the
same speed I hope so because this would
push the industry forward Ratchet and
Clank rift apart is a ps5 exclusive
project Athiya was next to be revealed a
Square Enix published game for ps5 and
PC it looked a great deal like the
Unreal Engine 5 reveal last month
project a Thea is a story focused
action-adventure title in which the
leading lady is found in a new world
filled with creatures and unknown
entities the gameplay looks fast with
third-person parkour segments and
combats and there's a little summoning -
a thing of note here is the name project
a Thea usually when the title project is
applied the game is years away but on
first impressions this could be sent
with sacrifice crossed with control and
that sounds mighty interesting to me
chalk this one up as a ps5 exclusive &
pc2 but do note Xbox players you will
get this you just have to wait a damn
long time and then we saw stray a
third-person cat adventure
it's like cyberpunk with cats and robots
don't you buy the backpack we have some
sort of feline delivery service with a
focus on being stealthy and fast on our
feet and in the blurb it talks about
sometimes we need to be as annoying as
possible to the world's inhabitants my
kind of game the cat has a drone too to
operate yeah it's weird this looks very
strange and quite unique quite niche
game releasing on PS 5 ps4 and PC but
coming to other consoles later sauce
tray is a console timed exclusive for
PlayStation next we had a new game
called R eternal a pretty cool premise
here if you've ever seen the movie edge
of tomorrow you know what to expect
return all sees our character stuck on
an alien planet surviving the horrors
only to relive the same day over and
over again
kinda like a loop but following each
death the world disfigures and corrupts
changing the gameplay we find we are -
changing after each death and adapting
to the planet this game has so much
potential but to stick with the original
question is this a ps5 exclusive yes yes
it is if you want to play horror
Groundhog Day in space you can only do
that on PS 5 Sackboy a big adventure
appeared next and this is an easy one
sackboy is a Sony property so this is
another PlayStation exclusive it looks
like a rebranding of the
to Big Planet franchise into a 3d
platformer both in solo campaign all
those good old sessions of co-op chaos
next up was destruction all-stars a game
which attempts to evolve the rocket
League formula by making car X the
priority this looks really impressive to
me with another added mechanic allowing
characters to leave their vehicles this
then is a multiplayer online destruction
arena and guess what
once again this is completely a ps5
exclusive and to have a game-changing
multiplayer game like this at launch is
pretty mind-blowing Kenner Bridge of
spirits was the next game to be revealed
with an art style which smashes together
Japanese and European influences and
looks damn adorable
another story-driven adventure with
combat which seems to be influenced by
The Legend of Zelda but if you're going
to be inspired by a game series your
males will make it one of the best ones
ever made the kicker in this game are
these beautiful little bus they can be
trained to change the environment and
progress the story forward damn it
they're cute Kanna bridge of spirits
will be available on PS 5 and PC via the
epic store at launch but once again it's
a timed exclusive meaning Xbox players
you've gotta wait goodbye volcano hi
popped up next a narrative adventure
with humanoid dinosaurs
say no more PS 5 and PC on day 1 Xbox
are frozen out of launch I don't think
they'll mind on this one to be honest
the next game revealed was that of odd
world soul storm if you know the
brilliance of Abe's Oddysee from back on
the ps1 you'll instantly be happy to see
odd world return going back to their 2d
ish routes and delivering the crude
comedy we love in a side scroller
looking beautifully modernized in terms
of exclusivity soul storm is confirmed
for PS 5 ps4 and PC and yep another
timed exclusive on console ghost wire
Tokyo was the next game revealed with
gameplay shown throughout ghost wire is
from the legendary Japanese game
producer Shinji Mikami and his team
known for Resident Evil and vanquish
amongst loads of others we inhabit Tokyo
after 99 percent of the city's
population has disappeared luckily we
have superpowers of sorts and do battle
with spirits that wrong
world as we fight through the game we
purge the darkness from our home looks
like fun
go swaiiow tokyo released on PS v on pc
and is yet another timed exclusive on
console during 2021 so once again xbox
players are forced to wait
it looks like Sony is taking a more
aggressive approach to PS 5 and
targeting Xbox players how do you feel
about that next up is a cinematic indie
game named yet the far shore and
interstellar trip to new planet to carve
out a future for humanity not really
much more information to gather from
this one jet drops on PlayStation and PC
with Xbox once again forced to wait bad
times bro God fall came out swinging
next with a trailer which seemed very
out of place and totally different from
the last one we saw but now it
definitely looks like a lightning fast
combo hack and slash a thorn with unique
classes weapons and godlike abilities
the kicker for this project is it can be
played solo duo or three people in coop
whatever you see fit
God four will be a launch title on PS 5
and will also be available on PC it will
get to Xbox but once again it's a timed
exclusive another indie game popped up
next in the shape of solar ash releasing
in 2021 if you've ever played journey or
fury you have the vibe here a mysterious
world to uncover with huge enemy
encounters all linked together by a
gripping story and unique neon art style
available on ps4 and PC as a theme going
on here isn't there Xbox you are forced
to wait next is one of my favorite games
of all time hitman returns with a number
3 at the end this is the final part of
agent 47s world of assassination trilogy
it's extremely close to dropping in
January 2021 I don't think anyone is new
to this right but just in case it's a
small open-world sandbox in which agent
47 takes out the target and tries not to
be seen or killed there are great games
they really are and just in case you're
wondering hitman three releases on ps4
ps4 PC and Xbox devices man I am hyped
for that game over - a piece of free
software now Astros playroom this game
will come pre-installed on all PS 5s and
acts like a demo of sorts well a series
of demos
it's essentially a 3d platformer which
shows off the cool things the new dual
sense controller has to offer and as
you'd expect is a ps5 exclusive but if
we're honest well I'll play on day one
and then delete it from existence
happy days did you see little devil
inside this indie game looks damn
impressive set in the Victorian times we
are tasked with finding something out
about this professor dude but it's the
scale and variety of tasks at hand
Monster Hunter esque fights followed by
exploration and even a poop joke what's
not to love finding information on this
game is extremely hard but the trailer
has the timed exclusive logo which means
it's another wait for our Xbox brothers
and sisters but it will be available on
PC next game NBA 2k 21 it's more NBA
from 2k and it's out on everything let's
move on game 20 of the night is bug
snacks a game in which eating critters
turns our bodies into that food group
it's perfectly weird for a game made by
the depths of octodad's
releasing at launch on PS 5 it's also on
ps4 and PC - and yep it's another
console exclusive now get this one in
your brain box demon souls completely
remade for PS 5 if you've ever played
Sakura or neo or Dark Souls this game is
the reason you have those a punishing
action role-playing game which created a
genre we all love to hate or maybe hate
to love the original was a PlayStation
exclusive and the updated version
remains that way one for the funds of
self-punishment I think here's another
game I am personally so stoked for death
loop remember the game we saw earlier
with the repeating day well death loop
is a similar notion but a completely
different direction and approach we are
tasked with assassinating a target but
we must fight through all his minions to
get there every time we die we find
ourself looped and we simply try again
pretty cool right well to add to that
your target has a dynamic bodyguard
tasked with taking you down playing just
like dishonored this is gonna be a great
game and it's here for launch season on
PS 5 and in terms of exclusivity
sorry Xbox it's another wait for you but
PC players you can grab this on day one
I'm honestly sold down for death
Loup next we had some resident evil
goodness thrown upon us with re8 village
it's going back to the first person
perspective like the last numbered
iteration did and Chris Redfield an
Ethan buff returned to go to Romania
this time hang on
that's Transylvania with all the
werewolves okay
I'm completely in for this can't wait
but what about exclusivity this one is
for everyone PS 5 xbox on PC all happy
and equal together in that nice sorry
hang on Chris Redfield is the bad guy
what the the penultimate game of the PS
5 reveal is another cat game well to be
honest I have no idea what's going on on
this one it's prog matter
set for release in 2022 we have zero
information on this it's basically a
teaser without context any ideas
pragmatic on all next-gen hardware and
PC - I have no more to add here but I do
like the cat x-ray mechanic I hope
that's important in the full game and
now game 25 of the reveal the next
horizon game titled horizon forbidden
West if you played the first game you
know how big a deal this is we pick back
up with a loin as she ventures further
into post-apocalyptic America and
continues to fight those Robo dinosaurs
and now there's new life to be nurtured
but there's a deadly plant growing over
the land and a light must go full
eco-warrior to sort this one out or lack
of Blastoise horizon forbidden West will
only be available on PlayStation this is
a full exclusive it's time now to go
through the mathematics of all these
games out of the 25 revealed for ps5 how
many do you think you can play elsewhere
we'll check this out all 25 are
available on PS 5 of course with 16 on
day one for PC and 4 available on day
one for Xbox players but if they wait
long enough it has the potential to go
up to 16 that's 9 games that can only be
played on PlayStation 5 when compared to
a PC and 21 games that can only be
played on PS 5 compared to an Xbox Sony
is definitely gunning for a strong first
year and by the looks of it want you
Xbox players to join the family so now I
hand this over to you give me your
opinions in the comments where do you
stand on exclusivity and are you happy
sad annoyed and glad
about what you've just witnessed I'm
Adam from Playstation grenade thanks for
your time I'll see you soon